Every woman who is successful,
regardless of the field
that she works in or appears in,
is deemed to be the
exception that proves the rule.
And every time a woman,
in whatever field, fails
she is simply,
well she's a woman isn't she?
To quote, "The glass ceiling
may have been cracked
but it certainly hasn't
been brought down yet."
The options that were
available to my gender then
were pretty much, you were a child
and then you left school.
The next big step for you
was getting married actually.
I think that has dramatically changed
over quite a few decades
but we are still a really long
way away from genuine equality
as far as gender is concerned.
The central driving, dramatic engine
of virtually every play, was a male.
Women were still the adjunct.
It was virtually unheard of
for there to be a woman director
but nobody ever commented on that
because that was the tradition,
that was the way
everybody had grown up in.
It was not exclusive to the theatre
it was the whole of life.
The primary voices were always male.
I am still stunned at the way
contemporary dramatists
do not find women interesting.
When I first entered Parliament
as a member
there was a strong sense, I think,
that I was some kind of diva
or that I was a complete airhead.
I would fall flat on my face
or I would expect special treatment.
None of that was true.
It was pretty much a white,
middle-aged, male-dominated chamber.
The egos that I saw
marching up and down those corridors
would not have been tolerated for
30 seconds in a professional theatre.
I mean, somebody said to me,
"How are you going to manage in what
is essentially a man's club?"
and I said, "But that's been
my experience all my life."
So in one sense I think
every woman is well-fitted.
The fact that it's a male
didn't worry me.
As we get older those
harsh definitions of our gender
begin to fracture.
They begin to slip apart a bit.
They become a bit foggy.
Those begin to change
and I found that very useful.
Every woman knows
she's experienced it in something.
Either she didn't get a job
she's qualified for
or someone's tried to put her off
whatever she wants to do.
We read every year
about these big guys in the City
and their bonuses with more noughts
after them than a donut shop
and still not enough women
on boards and things of that nature.
They are provable and definable
but we can't delude ourselves
to think that
what happens in a city boardroom
doesn't happen in a little shop or...
Do you know what I mean?
It's simply endemic.
You have to keep pushing away at it,
I mean, you have to keep
banging the same drum.
You have to tediously say the same
thing over and over and over again.
I mean it's kind of,
well it's a cliché,
but it isn't really a
rule of thumb in the theatre that
you have to say something three times
before an audience hears it.
But certainly changing the actual
structure of societies
and having it accepted as a norm
that women actually can do anything
if they are afforded
the same opportunities,
the same in-roads into learning
that is an automatic given
to the other gender,
then we can achieve
and we can work together
and we can make
hopefully a better world.
But there are no silver bullets.
It takes more than one campaign.
It takes more than one argument.
And it's hard but it can be done.
We have seen improvements made.
We're by no means
near the promised land
but we're quite a way up the hill.